thank you
[Music]
do you guys uh know anything about
what's going on with Kanye and Adidas
right now yes a little bit what's going
on with them saw that well he's been
posting a bunch of like crazy stuff uh
but is it crazy
it is it is uh it's it's igniting a lot
of things I saw him tweet about
um Kim Kardashian having diarrhea more
than the average person that's funny
that's that's good I actually have
legitimate questions about that was that
real I bet it is because did you guys
see that one you know how Connie is so
he yes starting to interrupt but he's
not on Instagram and he's been posting
all these comments about Adidas and GAP
but then people were standing around a
screen grab where it looked like someone
else doctor Kane complaining about Kim
having diarrhea I can tell you that I
authenticated you found a little
hologram I found a little hologram
sticker there's a little stockx he
looked it up and he just put a marker on
his phone and stuff I'm sorry I'm
dedicated there are a lot of people that
do do that with his tweets like there
was that one with that he said to uh
Courtney Cox that apparently wasn't him
you know how like uh order Jennifer
Aniston was like guys don't vote for
Kanye it's not funny when he was running
Jennifer Aniston really said that yeah
and then somebody posted a tweet from
him saying friends wasn't funny
but he never
she's like oh man if people vote for
Kanye I gotta get the message out she
was really like concerned about that but
then apparently like that was never him
but everyone thought it was really him
and then like recently
what this diarrhea tweet is that
but I see it circulate so much and every
time someone sends it to me they're like
dude did you see this I'm like is it
real they're like I don't know and it's
really more like I don't care yeah right
it's like your chain it's like doesn't
matter yeah thank you thank you that's
the thing where like a lot of these guys
they have like a team that have their
login
so is it them is it not them like who
knows but the thing is is if it's real
Kim is ruined forever like if I if if
that butt is really that stinky
he's no longer a sex it doesn't work
diaries
when you're diarrhea that's what I'm
saying like constantly
if she came about hot girls have IBS
it's
it's your problems that comes from being
attractive I don't know about that a lot
of pressure to carry they only eat
french fries if Kim K is filling her
pants up all the time I think that's
going to be a big problem big problem
for a brand maybe that's why her butt's
so big she also has a diaper she got
diapers definitely fill in those pants
you really think so no do you think she
has to put rubber bands around her
ankles
people from so it doesn't spill out yeah
it doesn't leak out yeah sometimes you
use parachute pants I don't think it
makes her any less attractive or
powerful at all in fact I think it
humanizes her I can relate yeah I think
it makes her disgusting her brand deals
it makes her disgusting trash
diarrheal medication Pepto-Bismol would
probably be your biggest dude that's a
whole other market right yeah I get
diarrhea Imodium Kim Kardashian collab
that's true yeah it makes Imodium
I would buy it or she goes organic and
she's like here's lentils they're great
that's a whole industry that's that's
been dying to like you know make
sexualize their products so it's perfect
that's true they thought it couldn't be
so the thing that happened with Adidas
basically Kanye and Adidas had some kind
of disagreement with uh the Yeezy slides
and the adolette sandal and uh probably
a lot of other things went wrong and now
he's saying that Adidas was offering him
a billion dollar buyout to shut the [ __ ]
up you you don't think Kanye is easy to
work with
I don't know Bobby he seems like a team
player
like a real chill guy Pitch Perfect dead
pen Pitch Perfect so Connie I think
Kanye's rebuttal to that is why would I
take that if I'm like look I'm
forecasted to make 500 million a year
exactly so he's like if I make 500
million a year you're offer me 2x of
what I'm gonna make yeah and then so I
don't know if you guys follow Kanye on
Instagram what he started doing is he
started posting all the board members of
Adidas like the old people that are like
in Germany or whatever wow over and over
the girls send love to these guys send
love to these guys and there's like he's
posted like 20 of them which is crazy is
that considered doxing
I I think it's all if it's information
yeah and he would say like he's like you
guys think I'm [ __ ] around he goes
this is like just the start of it he
goes you guys if you guys want to [ __ ]
around I'll keep [ __ ] do you guys
think that this is a rip-off design I
think it's definitely inspired but this
is old hat for these companies bigger
Brands you work with we're kind of
talking about this earlier with your
shoes you have an artist collaborator
come in on like a tier zero Halo product
and then they do derivatives of them for
the mass market and so that keeps this
product exclusive and special and then
this is the accessible one that the
everyday joke so that's the standard
model that they all that's everyone does
that when we were working we worked with
Adidas many times and one of our popular
shoes it was like this um kind of soccer
looking shoes orange and blue and three
six it was uh it was kind of like a
campus what was it it was it was kind of
like a gazelle it was kind of like a
Samba but it was a skateboarding soccer
hybrid shoe and um you were obviously in
charge of it right yeah I could tell
but the uh like six months later they
issued the exact same shoe and they just
took our logo off what yeah and then
that was for the mass Market it's
annoying but it's a part of but it's the
same shoe they use us for market
research and they get us to do to Hype
up the brand and the product can't get
people that acclimated to that specific
model and then everyone's like I want
that it's just so expensive or there
aren't enough of them and they're like
well for the mass Market we'll make
billions of these you know it kind of
looks like that and feels like that but
it's not it so people in this industry
that are getting into a deal like that
already know that that's part of it they
should know that they should know that
that's what's happening I mean I'm I'm
sure Kanye also knew that and just
probably stipulated in his contract they
weren't allowed to do it but then it's a
great area you know it's really hard to
copyright it's but you can't patent
fashion designs and especially with
copyrights it gets kind of murky so like
who's to say that this also doesn't kind
of look like that yeah right
in fact
shots fired Kanye shot back
holy [ __ ] because the artist would be
like no that's my [ __ ] work God damn
it and he's like it looks like a [ __ ]
Starbucks cup holder you idiot the
jury's like oh I never thought of that
whoa that's not what I'm saying Kanye I
never want to be on the other side
there's like no greater fear of mine
than to be culturally eradicated by
Kanye on Instagram but at the same time
I also think it would probably be like
the best PR move oh yeah he might say
you have diarrhea yeah at least I just
write that Kanye has success if that's
all he's got is playground insults it's
pretty exciting it is it is when when
this happens with Kanye and Brands like
Gap Nike Adidas do you do you think that
those companies really see this as like
PR opportunity or are they actually
freaking out like I'm sure parts of them
if they weren't prepared for this might
be a little bit annoyed but in the end I
think it actually only does good for
Adidas I mean that's all people are
talking about right now and I don't
believe that all PR is good PR do you
know how they say that they love to say
marketing yeah I don't
his old feed was all these he just break
them all he erased all of them there's
just one back to one post you know what
was cool about the executive board that
he was posting was that one of them was
Jackie Joyner Christmas which I never
knew I didn't know that either yeah
that's crazy yeah that actually I think
makes Adidas look more interesting
that's pretty tight instead of like this
faceless executive board now it's like
we know people I thought it was all like
Norwegians or something yeah I thought
it was like a board of dudes that looked
like the penguin
they're not wearing Adidas top hats and
[ __ ] yeah you know you're kind of
looking like the penguin right now you
get them there man yeah
that's my goal to be an old fat Tycoon
with one monocle do you think there's
any grounds to Kanye saying it'll cost
you billions to keep me and billions to
let me go I mean I think there is some
truth probably to that but that's a deal
that they knew that they were getting to
he Kanye did something very similar with
Nike before right and this is just he
has a track record of doing this so
Adidas I think they Adidas and GAP when
they signed on with Kanye they knew what
was down the road in case you know you
never hire someone you can't fire right
and so if you're a smart business person
would know that and so when you're going
into a relationship with Connie you know
at some point it's gonna the road is
gonna have to split and you have to like
think about what is it still worth it
the cost benefit of us working with us
for the bad PR nightmare at the end of
it is it still gonna be worth it and I
think for them it's probably very much
worth it everyone's been saying who else
is gonna like why would a company want
to work with them after this every
Company still wants to work with him are
you kidding he's made he made it Adidas
relevant for like seven years now they
had no other model if I'm the board
members I get a [ __ ] way ahead of
this thing what do you do what do you do
I'm like we have very solid stools we I
haven't had diarrhea in like probably
seven years a lot of fiber in my diet a
lot I eat a lot of it a lot of fruit
salad because I don't want him to
destroy my reputation he's on the next
stage execs I'm gonna [ __ ] call out
how many of you guys have IBS yeah he's
gonna come after you you can just like
be Rabbit eight mile and then just start
claiming all of it up front too yeah
just out of nowhere say like a we're
sorry production's delayed because we
all have bad diarrhea and then Connie
can't yeah you can't use it I get my
assistant I take a tick tock video of
her walking out of a bathroom that I
just went to and I'm like look my
assistant's fine and she's like she's
like
it doesn't smell if uh Kanye hit you up
tomorrow and was like Bobby I want to
work with the hundreds would you do
anything specific with that contract or
would you be like all right go crazy
dude I would entertain the conversation
I don't know it would depend on exactly
what like if it made 10 more lawyers
just to make sure this works I don't
think he abides by lawyers I don't think
he abides by any system but are you
afraid that he's gonna make fun of your
diarrhea problems no I make fun of my
diarrhea problems so it would ruin you
bro yeah no it would make me better I
don't think he could ruin me anymore I
would just [ __ ] jump off a building
it's the worst thing that can happen to
you is someone excuse me canceled yeah
exactly you're done dude you'll never
sell another t-shirt ever again exactly
if people think I'm filling my boxes up
every day I'm [ __ ] did you ever did
you ever come close to working with I
thought you're gonna say diarrhea he's
worn our product before but I've never
no if you got to pitch Kanye would you
have a pitch for him something that you
would pitch him I don't I think it's
gonna be interesting when he enters web
3 because I know he talks bad about nfts
but he's also curious and he's been
going around talking to certain people
that'll be interesting because he's all
about decentralization and people owning
the art and all this stuff about cutting
out the middlemen yeah so when he
figures out that part of it I think that
can actually be pretty disruptive I
don't think it's exactly there yet
because nfts are still in the stage of
like million dollar monkey picture that
isn't going to really work for Kanye but
I think he's going to look at the system
somehow and be like oh this is how we
can make sure artists are getting paid
or the community's owning brands or you
know that aspect of web3 like that's so
Kanye I think Connie thinks he's on web
four but you'd have to Rebrand a web for
yes that I I actually know someone who
had a meeting with him and Kane said I
want you to forget what three I want to
do web for and he's like what is that
that's so sick what does that even
means I'll forget this web three yeah I
would pitch him I would pitch him I'd be
like I'd be like Kanye what are things
that we know facts that we know about
the world everybody wants to have sex
with Kanye West and he's like he's like
hey would he disagree with that he's
like okay
what's your next thing here's what we do
we do Kanye specific licensed Kanye blow
up dolls for all the women and some of
the men out there who want to have sex
with Kanye and I think he would actually
go for it and actually launch it on his
Instagram and everything that's my yeah
you're probably not wrong that sounds
like web four